you talk a lot in the book I've known
you for a very long time there's a lot
about you I didn't know that I learned
and you talk a lot it's just fantastic
it's funny it's also very instructive
what's interesting is that for a lot of
us who knew you as a comedy writer and
performer
it was a strange period of time when you
were elected to the Senate because you
made a conscious effort not to be funny
and you talked about this in the book
but you thought that that would maybe be
detrimental to your career well what am
was I won my race by 312 votes it was
the closest race in history but I said
and I and they had used a lot of what I
had done in comedy and put it through a
machine called the D humor Iser a
fifteen million dollar machine built
with state-of-the-art Israeli technology
all the humor from anything just leave
it as something offensive so when I got
the Senate I just said I'm just gonna
what I have to prove to the people of
Minnesota that I'm gonna be a workhorse
and I'm gonna be serious so I just would
not I just had to and I asked my staff
to be the D humor Iser and they were
they were very good one of the things he
did as a senator is is you write you
write to constituents you're right now
it's in the first note I got there's a
woman in Minnesota
Ruth Anderson who's turning 110 so it's
my first note to congratulate Ruth on
turning a hundred and ten and I'm a
comedy writer so I'm saying on my desk
and I go dear Ruth you have a bright
future
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my assistant takes it and and my chief
of staff comes back and about about a
minute later goes what's this I said
well it's a joke I thought she'd enjoy
it and he goes aha and you think her
family will enjoy it you think her
grandchildren will enjoy it and I went
like oh yeah you're right okay and so I
didn't do that it's just my there was a
ruling I think he did there was a Korean
Court ruling on marriage equality and
which is a great historic ruling 5-4 and
Scalia wrote this terrible obnoxious
dissent
so I told my staff that I wanted to put
out a press release saying senator frank
al franken of Minnesota today applauded
the Supreme Court's decision on marriage
equality but called Justice Scalia's
dissent quote very gay
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and they want no no no on and this is
after I was reelected yeah at that point
I was going like I could do that yeah we
didn't do that
you